well can you imagine buying a car only
to find out it's been stolen that's
exactly what happened to a Summerlin
woman well now she's out not only the
car but also the money she paid for it 8
news now reporter Brian will explains
how you can avoid becoming a victim of
this type of scam
so everything seemed okay the the title
uh VIN number matched the vehicle Diana
nagibe went on offer up she found a 2007
Dodge Ram 1500 that would help her get
to work he had me meet up uh
in a lot with vehicles she gave him a
seven thousand six hundred dollars for
the truck that's when she took it here
to the DMV and found out that new
vehicle she just bought was stolen she
filed a police report with North Las
Vegas police department and they
impounded and recovered the vehicle and
sent it back to Nye County
um at that point she's out the vehicle
um because she didn't purchase it from a
licensed dealer she's also out the money
she gave him these kind of scams are
becoming frequent according to the DMV
as many as two stolen vehicles are
discovered at their van inspection
stations every week JD Decker with the
DMV says to avoid a scam like this never
buy a vehicle off a social media website
always buy from a licensed dealer and
make sure the title matches also look
out for these red flags someone's trying
to induce you into paying cash for a
vehicle by making the price very
attractive it's likely that that person
is trying to sell it quick for a reason
that you're not aware of and now that
lot where she bought the vehicle is
empty she has a message for the person
that cheated her there's better ways to
make money than to scam people